now first I've gotta ask you about a
chapter that's closing we're actually
done on Wednesday we have a few more
days and it's very strange I woke up
this morning was 5 a.m. and it was so
hard to wake up and then I was like oh
wait you can't some play and this is the
last Monday it's weird you know it's
exciting is sad it's you know we all
feel really proud of what we've done but
it's just weird it almost was like
graduating high school or something what
was the most emotional moment so far we
all got really really fury eyed at the
table read because well I can't tell you
what happens but they're sort of a
recreation of sorts and just to hear
that out loud was pretty emotional and
the last scene where you see all the
girls together is just like of course
this was like heart-wrenching so that
was pretty as pretty in today can fans
have hope for a happy ending how would
you describe the ish there will be happy
moments you know it is you know the
nature of our show things can't go
perfectly well
but there are a happy moment you will
smile you will cry this is what do you
think Wednesday's gonna be like what are
you guys gonna do on that last day I
think it's supposed to be an extremely
long day but I think we're all gonna go
out together after work which would be
nice do you feel excited or nervous at
all about what snack yeah I think a
little of both I mean the unknown is
definitely really scary but you know I'm
I'm excited I think it's nice to have
options to sort of be in a position
where I can choose what I want to do
next or if I want to take time off and
like I that's why I love my job I never
know what's gonna happen next so I'm
sort of in this like giddy like ooh what
am I going to be doing next week babe so
let's see I don't we interesting